[Applaudissements]
bonjour euh
on a tous nos héros moi quand j'étais
petit j'avais plein de héros et son goku
forcément était petit sourire énorme et
est très énergique
après j'ai eu l'envié n'est guère bon
très musclé moins à l'aise avec le
sourire ils sont un peu plus crispé
après sur bourdieu un sociologue
français moins musclé que je n'ai guère
mais ils réfléchissent et énormément et
j'aimais beaucoup sa pensée où j'ai
beaucoup aimé parce que tu es un peu
plus tard que sont beaucoup et ils
avaient tous un truc en commun ces gens
là ces gens là ils s'étaient tous battus
il avait tout fait pour s'extraire de
leur conditionnement il avait mérité
leur sort et leur avenir et je trouvais
ça admirable et ça me faisait beaucoup
pensé à cette scène vous savez d'un film
qui s'appelle total rico où arnold
schwarzenegger se sort une immense puces
du nez là une puce rugit et pour rouge
et cela sort pour arriver à être libre
pour qu'on arrête de l'observer et il
avait mérité sa liberté parce que
vraiment ils se l'étaient à arracher du
fin fond du cerveau de la manière dont
je suis un gars c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui est sorti de sa campagne
autrichienne et qui a développé des
muscles énorme les premiers pectoraux
mondiaux à pouvoir et tu fais tout fait
des buffles ensuite il est devenu quand
même gouverneur de la sixième puissance
mondiale la californie donc ça c'est
quand même assez exceptionnel et en gros
je sais pas si vous avez déjà vu mais il
ya des des speechs de motivation de
chance donnée guerre sur internet
pourquoi j'ai eu du succès et vous
regardez le speech et vous avez mais
vous êtes en transferts le truc c'est du
délire quand vous sortez du speech nous
avons envie de vous mettre à parler
anglais avec un accent autrichien à copé
à l'amour à la machette
ensuite vous avez envie de vous mettre 1
go fleith etc ça dure content je vous
rassure et et en raw ça tous ces gens là
tous ces airs tous mes héros de mon
enfance il avait il allait du mérite et
après il ya des gens qui ont moins de
mérite
il ya par exemple l'aller le couple
trippin donc ça c'est c'est le couple
américain avec l'instinct maternel et
paternel hitlérien qui ont éduqué leurs
traits enfants dans leur cave en les
laissant sortir une fois par an pour
qu'il se douche en les enchaînant olive
vous imaginez le truc sordide c'était
vraiment un drame affreux vers les
enquêteurs s'en sont jamais remis
d'ailleurs il raconte les histoires
c'est moins horrible et e
quand on voit leur camp on se dit le ils
sont le mal ils ont choisi le mal est en
gros quelle que soit la sentence qui
vont avoir
ils l'ont mérité et en fait c'est sur
cette même notion un peu floue de mérite
qu'on va baser plein de nos
raisonnements et notamment plaints de
non justification de je suis dans cette
école c'est quelque part je me suis
battu pour y être si j'ai ce salaire
c'est alors peut-être que c'est un peu
injuste mais en même temps moi j'ai
travaillé pour l'avoir et je le mérite
et quand on dit qu'on le mérite ça veut
dire que implicitement on dit que
d'autres le mérite - et ça c'est un truc
que moi je trouve hyper important c'est
que en gros nos méritocratie sont
fondées dans le système idéal qu'on veut
tous les méritocratie sont fondés sur
cette notion de mérite et andy
méritocratie c'est bien ça veut bien
dire ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'en
gros on va avoir notre position sociale
en fonction du mérite dont on va faire
preuve et andy méritocratie on dit pas
et figures ainsi parce que les filles
tracy ça serait un système où les gens
les plus compétents et les plus
efficaces à un poste donné serait à
cette couche l' essence dit bien que
c'est injuste parce qu'en gros là
compétence ça dépend vraiment de
l'éducation qu'on a eu de la famille
d'arik aller on a été éduquée et si on
trouve que la méritocratie c'est plus
sain c'est plus juste c'est parce qu'on
se dit au fond de nous ce truc le mérite
tout le monde ya accès quel que soit ce
qu'on y met derrière on se dit tout le
monde ya accès parce que si on veut être
méritant on peut être méritant et est en
fait derrière ce tout le monde peut
vouloir être méritant il ya une autre
croyance un autre fondement notre
société qui s'appelle le libre arbitre
et en gros pourquoi on pense qu une
méritocratie est juste c'est parce qu'en
gros on pense que tout le monde
à cette capacité de choisir de vouloir
raid méritants parce que il peut faire
appel à son libre arbitre
donc prenons et prenez un choix
classique mois que j'ai dans ma vie
parce que j'ai des grands choix à faire
dans ma vie c'est soit je vais manger un
bout hier soir soit je mange un burrito
grand choix s'il en est et on va essayer
de de faire une investigation du ce que
ça veut dire le libre arbitre et je vous
rassure ça fait 2000 ans que les
philosophes s'écharpent sur cette notion
c'est pas un 10 minutes qu'on va la
résoudre
mais je vous propose juste d'y réfléchir
un petit peu plus que ce qu'on a
l'habitude d'y penser
parce que je pense qu'il ya un grand
débat hyper intéressant entre les
philosophes et ans roger juste
l'impression moi pour me pencher un
petit peu depuis quelques années que ce
débat hyper riches quand les philosophes
ne ruisselle pas sur notre vision nous
du monde et sur la capacité qu'ont à
avoir du mérite à ne pas en voir etc
c'est comme si on s'était pas enrichi de
ce débat alors que je le pense
extrêmement riche
donc ok le libre arbitre il suppose le
libre arbitre au sens classique du terme
au sens où moi je ressens que j'ai du
libre arbitre
il repose sur deux choses la première
chose c'est le fait que le choix si on
rejoue la scène plusieurs fois hier dans
la même situation dans mon même et à
l'émotionnel etc etc
mais il ya des fois je choisir vos
bonnes il ya des fois je vais choisir
burrito sinon aussi à chaque fois choisi
bout du si à chaque fois sur les 1000 cc
je choisis la même chose il n'y a pas
vraiment de choix donc c'est hyper liés
au déterminisme donc le libre arbitre
classique est classiquement il suppose
que ya eu une petite alerte
indétermination premier concept
nécessaire au libre arbitre deuxième
concept c'est le concept de la source
ultime dire qu'à un moment cette
indétermination il faut que j'en sois
l'origine la source ultime
parce que en gros si l'indétermination 1
vient de un dieu qui me disait
le burrito franchement il est bon bah de
suite ça fait moins libre arbitre donc
du coup il faut que l'indétermination
elles viennent de moi très bien donc
reprenons le déterminisme pour ceux qui
sont pas forcément à l'aise avec cette
notion
c'est vraiment la notion que tous les
événements y sont dus en vertu du
principe de causalité
ça veut dire qu'en gros tout événement
est dû à des causes en périodes
antérieures qui le déterminent
complètement et en gros la philosophie
du déterminisme ça veut dire que si on
rejouait le big bang il ya 13 8
milliards d'années avait les mêmes
conditions initiales 13,8 milliards
d'années plus tard y aurait un sapience
en face de vous en train de dire les
mêmes choses parler de burrito et de
bobines et vous auriez la même réaction
ça veut vraiment dire ça le déterminisme
absolu
donc ça il ya aussi un grand débat 6 est
ce que le monde est absolument
déterministe ou pas ce qui est sûr c'est
que la science et la technologie avec ce
qu'elle prédisent nous dise quand même
que si notre société fonctionne comme
elle fonctionne c'est quand même que à
un niveau macroscopique le déterminisme
est quand même extrêmement importants
dont la place pour que le libre arbitre
se développe elle est déjà assez
immensément petit déjà c'est la première
chose mais prenant le meilleur des cas
que quand même il ya une détermination
qu'il est possible c'est à dire qu'en
gros il ya des événements qui
jaillissent et qui sont indépendamment
indépendant de toute cause antérieur ça
c'est pas évident déjà dans l'esprit
d'un ingénieur un événement qui sort
sans cause antérieures c'est déjà un peu
bizarre mais acceptons que ça existe ok
donc maintenant étudiant la deuxième le
deuxième concept qu'il est nécessaire
d'avoir pour le libre arbitre
c'est à dire la source ultime que nous
soyons la source ultime de joshua c'est
à dire que cette indétermination qu'il
est possible peut-être qu'elles viennent
de nous deux la der de nous parce que si
elle vient d'autre part baissé - du
libre arbitre
ok alors prenons maintenant beaubourg et
au hockey
qu'est ce qui pourrait influer sur ce
choix
en gros il ya quatre choses qui peuvent
influer sur ce choix premièrement il ya
tous les facteurs extérieurs
le bund a été fermé j'ai choisi le
burrito j'ai regardé un film où il y
avait son goku qui se baserait avec des
baguettes et je me suis dit ah j'ai
envie d'un truc à elle et baguettes
ça me fait envie à mon pote qui m'a
parlé de son voyage au vietnam du coup
j'ai envie de manger un bout et ça c'est
des causes qui sont extérieurs à moi
déterminée ou indéterminée on s'en fiche
elles sont extérieurs à moi c'est pas
mon libre arbitre très très bien après
les facteurs internes imagine les tic 1
par exemple binger les jeunes que j'ai
parce que mes parents sont rencontrés et
je n'ai pas choisi il sera couplé après
jeu là encore moins choisis et moi je
les jeunes que j'ai géré a choisi du
tout très bien ensuite il ya un
troisième facteur c'est le caractère que
j'ai développée par ok et là il faut se
dire une chose c'est que au moment où je
fais mon choix beaucoup de burrito mon
caractère il est ce qu'il est et je
choisis pas de leur formaté à la demande
au moment où je fais mon choix au moment
où je fais mon choix je fais mon choix
en fonction de mon caractère qui est
peut-être issus d'une évolution où j'ai
eu un libre arbitre peut être avant mais
là en l'occurrence au moment où je suis
mon choix je l'est pas et il faut savoir
aussi que le raisonnement qu'ont allard
pour le libre arbitre et bien en fait on
peut l'avoir pour tous les choix
antérieurs qui ont forgé mon caractère
et sylla pour beaucoup de burrito on ne
trouve pas de place pour le libre
arbitre
on n'en trouvera pas avant non plus soit
quatrième possibilité la source ultime
j'ai un truc en moi une sorte de
fontaines à indétermination un truc d'où
va jaillir des événements qui roues qui
ont eu aucune cause intérieur qui vont
jaillir deux mois et qui vont aller hop
plutôt bonne plutôt brut et alors ça il
ya des gens qui ont un mot pour ça et
disent bien c'est l'âme
on a un truc qui m'a taillé en nous qui
choisit voilà d'où sort cette
indétermination et c'est très bien mais
en même temps moi je me dis mais cette
âme là à kehl mans je les choisis
à quel moment ce que je considère être
moins a choisi l'âme qui est source de
cette indétermination rachid solaire à
la distribution des sources
indétermination là
moi j'étais pas là j'ai rien choisi du
tout dans du coup au sens où j'entends
libre arbitre au sens où l'entend
liberté au sens où j'entends choix je ne
vois pas où j'ai du libre arbitre
après si on redéfinit les choses je veux
bien mais au sens populaire de libre
arbitre au sens populaire de liberté je
ne vois pas où c'est qu'est la place
pour le libre arbitre
pour moi il n'est pas immensément petit
il est juste inexistant au sens où je
l'entends au sens où je le comprends et
pour ça il ya une histoire moi je trouve
qu'il m'a fait passer du la
compréhension au ressenti c'est
l'histoire de charles whitman
il ya un philosophe américain qui en
parlent samaris je le cite parce que
c'est important
il en a il a parlé c'est lui qui a
trouvé l'exemple c'est hyper intéressant
son travail et il parle de cette
histoire dont charles whitman donc c'est
c'est un jeune homme voit plutôt plutôt
plutôt bien bien propre sur lui 25 ans
on né en 1966 sur un campus au texas eh
ben ils commencent à tirer sur tout le
monde
jamais été très safe de se balader sur
les campus au texas
donc en 1966 ça n'était pas non plus du
coup il commence à attirer un peu dans
le tas alors ils tirent sur une femme
enceinte et tire sur son copain qui se
demandaient si sa femme allait bien a
priori les deux ça va pas fort et est en
gros ce qui se passe c'est que bon la
police fait ce qu'elle a à faire et ce
qui est incroyable c'est qu'on retrouve
des notes de suicides chez lui et en
fait quand on lit ses notes c'est
bouleversant
vous les avez sur wikipédia en gros il
écrit que ça fait plusieurs mois qu'il a
des pensées irrationnelles qu'il
n'arrive pas à maîtriser il comprend pas
d'où elles viennent
il dit qu'il a vu plusieurs médecins et
que tous les médecins ont pas réussi à
l'aider il dit qu'il ne comprend pas son
geste qu'il ne comprend pas pourquoi il
a tué sa femme parce qu'il retrouve sa
femme aussi qu'il a tué avant le la
fusillade
il comprend encore moins pourquoi il a
tué sa mère qu'il aimait profondément
il demande à ce qu'on réalise une
autopsie sur son corps suite à ça
ces événements et il demande aussi est
ce que j'ai trouvé le plus fou c'est
qu'il dit j'ai une assurance si ça
fonctionne je veux que cette assurance à
une fondation pour la santé mentale pour
que ce genre de drame ne se reproduise
plus mais du coup il faut une autopsie
et trouve dans son cerveau une tumeur
qui pressait sur l'hypothalamus
l'endroit où il ya notamment la gestion
de la violence et du jugement hélas
quand on entend cette histoire on se dit
mais moi si j'avais la même d'une tumeur
au même endroit est ce que je serais
capable de maîtriser les comportements
négatifs que cela induirait chez moi et
ça c'est un peu l'équivalent de dire
ouais moi parkinson le joueur âgé
bronche pas wise haimer non je trop fort
en orientation ça ça ne concerne pas
c'est pour les autres c'est hyper
prétentieux de dire qu'on est au dessus
de ces déterminations l'a ensuite avec
notre réflexion c'est que je me dis si
l'ablation de cette tumeur ça aurait pu
changer son comportement
de la même manière que des médicaments
vont changer les choix qu'on va faire
qu'est ce que ça dit qu'est ce que ça
dit de notre libre arbitre
quand le fait qu'en une intervention
extérieure soit de la chirurgie ou la
prise de médicaments peut induire des
changements dans le comportement et dans
nos choix et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
de ce que la médecine sera capable de
faire demain et qui sera peut être
encore plus fines dans l'orientation de
nos joies et ensuite on se dit une
troisième chose c'est six mois j'avais
grandi dans la peau dans les gènes de
charles whitman que j'avais eu la même
tumeur que j'avais eu exactement les
mêmes événements dans ma vie est-ce que
j'aurais été vraiment libres de faire
autrement oui parce que moi j'ai une âme
qui aurait fait autrement oui mais et si
tu avais eu l'art mais namco charles
whitman
qu'est ce qui se serait passé et je sais
pas moi en tout cas dans ma définition
de ça c'est le journal qui présente
j'avais oublié de et en gros on se dit
qu'est ce qu'on aurait pu faire moi ça
dans la version que j'ai du libre
arbitre
je ne sais pas si j'en ai en tout cas
j'ai de sérieux doutes parce que je ne
vois pas concrètement où il serait
et ça fait beaucoup penser à cette
phrase de schopenhauer qui dit l'homme
peuvent certes faire ce qu'il veut mais
il ne peut pas vouloir ce qu'il veut et
je dis pas ça pour dire on n'a pas les
bons arbitres du coup on ne doit pas
avoir de notions de liberté de notion de
responsabilité etc
je dis juste que de repenser le libre
arbitre de vraiment essayé de faire une
enquête sur ce que célibat arbitres de
ce que sa question de ce que ça remet en
question comment on redéfinit la notion
de liberté quand on se dit qu'on a pas
libre arbitre je pense que c'est des
choses hyper intéressante et sur
lesquelles il faudrait vraiment qu'on se
penche parce que en gros il faut pour
moi moi en tout cas je tire deux
conclusions de cette aventure ou de
cette investigation sur le libre arbitre
le premier c'est que je pense que en
tant que société il faudrait qu'on voit
les individus les humains ben comme des
concours de circonstances qui les amène
à faire des choses qui vont dans un sens
plutôt bien pour la société ou plutôt
mauvais et que c'est juste à ce titre là
qu'il faut inciter et peut-être punir
aussi mais pas parce que les gens sont
foncièrement mauvais ou foncièrement bon
parce que juste on essaie d'inciter un
concours de circonstances parce que la
seule chose que peut faire la société
c'est que c'est que ces circonstances ou
en tout cas les circonstances que la
société maîtrise face et oriente ce
concours de circonstances quel humain
dans un sens qui est le bon et ensuite
la de la deuxième chose qui je pense est
très importante c'est que
individuellement ne plus croire au libre
arbitre
ça implique aussi beaucoup d'humilité
parce que qui dit pas de libre arbitre
d'ipad mérite qui dit pas de mérite dit
pas de fierté qui dit pas de fierté dit
pas d'orgueil qui dit pas d'orgueil dit
pas d'arrogance et juste qu'on
remplacera par une une immense
reconnaissance d'avoir la chance pour
certains d'être là où ils sont et faire
ce qu'ils font et du coup j'en profite
pour vous dire merci beaucoup de m'avoir
écouté et merci immensément
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]